concerns were growing this morning about
a potential new wave of global cyber
attacks as a world heads back to work
starting on Friday an unprecedented hack
attack disabled computer networks in at
least 150 countries including the u.s.
the so called ransomware takes computers
hostage and then demands payment charlie
Daggett is outside a hospital in London
one of the dozens hit by the hack in the
UK charlie good morning good morning to
you is here that the scale of the
attacks began to emerge and then it
spread to places like Spain Germany of
course the United States soon it was
everywhere
hackers capitalizing on a weakness first
exposed by the NSA and then leaked
online the trouble is most big companies
will shut down computer systems over the
weekend what happens when all those
users log back on unprecedented
escalating and sweeping the globe ìletís
counters over 200,000 victims in at
least 150 countries widespread
disruptions were reported today
throughout Asia the frozen screen
warnings are much the same that started
here in Britain and spread across the
world employees found their files had
been encrypted no longer readable with
hackers demanding $300 in ransom to
decode them or they'd be destroyed the
malware program is called wanna cry and
it was first uncovered in documents
stolen from the US National Security
Agency exposing a vulnerability to
Microsoft operating systems it crippled
Britain's National Health Service
patients expecting scheduled operations
were turned away the worldwide attacks
could have been far worse if not for a
pair of cybersecurity researchers
including Darian HUS from Michigan who
stumbled on a kill switch hidden in the
domain name the hackers were using even
though the kill switch has been
activated there were at the very least
thousands and possibly even a hundred
thousand infections that occurred before
the kill switch was activated it may
have stopped the malware from spreading
to millions more computers it's hard to
feel like a hero I think because you
know I just documented my analysis it's
kind of what I
on a day-to-day basis so for me it was
just another day at the office I guess
but cybersecurity experts warn what's
happened so far is nothing compared to
what might be coming that might be
unstoppable the concern being that
potentially a new variant of this
ransomware could could show up on Monday
that would take a lot more effort to try
to stop that next wave of attack
Microsoft President Brad Smith said this
should serve as a wake-up call to
government's in a scathing statement
over the weekend he said an equivalent
scenario would be the US military having
its Tomahawk missile stolen Charlie
Charlie d'Agata in London thanks